그래서 여러분들 건물 매입하시는데
있어서
도움이 되셨으면 좋겠고 좀 이렇게
생각보다
신축 비용뿐만 아니라
다른 비용도 다 들어간다 대출
이자까지도 감안을 해야 된다 뭐 이런
것까지도 좀 알고 계시면 좋을 것
같습니다
[음악]
제가 오늘은
강남빌딩 50억원의 매입해서
신축까지 했을 때 비용이 어느 정도
드는지 한번 좀 설명을 해 드리려고
합니다
텍스트를 보고 같이 할 건데 매매가가
이제 50억원대
빌딩을 매입한다고 했을 때
취득 관련 비용이 한 대략 3억 정도
됩니다
취득세가 중간 안 받는다는 가정하에
50억이라고 치면은
4.6% 하면은 한 대략 한 2억
3천 정도 되는데 여기서 이제
중개수수료랑 이런 것까지 합치면은
대략 한 3억 정도
될 것으로 예상이 되고 이거는 이제
예시로든 겁니다 그래서 대출을 만약에
한 35억 정도 받았다
실제 현금은
취득세까지 3억 그다음에 35
빼면은
취득세까지 한 18억 정도 들어갑니다
매입하는 데까지 그 정도 들어가고
멸시라는데 비용이 좀 들어가요 대략
한
연면적이 100평 정도 된다고
가정하에 대략 금액입니다 대략 금액
한 4 5천 5천 정도는 되는 거
같아요 대략입니다 여러분들 그 거기
이제
지역이라든지 그 어느 정도
철거해야 되는 수준에 따라 좀 다르긴
하는데
멸실 비용이랑 그 다음에 건물을 또
설계 하잖아요 설계 비용까지
들어갑니다 여기 뭐 대략 한 1억
정도
기재를 했는데 아마 좀 더 들 수
있어요
멸실 비용도 좀 금액이 좀 많이
올라갔고 그리고 만약에 건물 규모가
좀 있다라고 하면은 그 해체심의를 또
받아야 돼요 그래서 해체심이 또
받아야 되고 기간이 더 걸리고
해체심이 하면서 그 해체 감리자도
지정을 해야 되거든요 해체 감리자는
그 이제 구청에서 지정해주는 건축사를
지정이 돼요 그래서 그것도 한 몇천만
원 정도 돼서 제가 봤을 때 1억이
아니라 거의 한 1억 5천 정도 될
것 같아요
신축 비용은 그냥 대략 한 18억
정도 들었다고 치면은
18억이면은 뭐 어떤 자재를 쓸지는
좀 모르겠지만 대략 한 180평 1
180평이
정도 된다는 가정하에 한 18억 정도
들었다고 치고 그리고
시설자금대출이 또 나와요이 지금 사례
같은 경우에는 그 법인이 설립된지
얼마 되지는 않았는데
그래도 시설 자금이 한이 정도
나왔어요 한 1억 5천 정도 들어가고
그 다음에 18억 한 19억 5천
정도 들어가는 건데 여기 시설자금 한
13억을 빼고
대출이 저희가 지금 13억이랑
35억쯤에
48억 이잖아요
48억에
요즘에 금리가 대략 한 5% 정도라고
가정했을 때 1년에 한 2억 4천
정도 됩니다 지금 여기서 이제 2억
4천을 더 더하고 여러분들이 또
마지막에 아셔야 될게 건물에 대해서
취득세를 내야 돼요 건물가액이 저희가
18억 이잖아요 거기서 한 3.5%
정도 됩니다
8억에
3.5%
하면은 대략 대략 한 7천만원 정도
되는 거 같아요
아까 8억 9천에
7천만원
하면은 거의 9억 6천 거의 10억
정도 됩니다
그래서 이걸 더하기 아까 18억
들어갔죠
그러면 대략 한 28억 정도 되는 것
같아요 건물 50억짜리 사서
신축비용 한 18억 정도 드린 다음에
건물을 짓는다라고 하면은
현금이 대략 한 28억 정도 들어가는
것 같습니다 여기서 아마 이제 좀
짜잘짜잘하게 비용 빠진게 있어요 뭐
몇백만원 뭐 인입비용이라든지 이런게
좀 빠지긴 했지만 한 28억
정도
물론 이제 사정에 따라 대출이 더
많이 나와서
현금이 좀 덜 들어갈 수도 있는데
법인이 그렇게 오래되지 않는다는
가정하에
산정을 했을 때 대략요 정도 되는 거
같습니다 그래서 보통은 여기까지는
생각을 못해요 대부분 다 이제 그냥
매입하는 비용만 생각을 하는데 뭐
멸실 비용도 들어가고 설계 비용도
들어가고 그 다음에 이자비용 1년치는
가지고 있어야죠 그래서이자 비용이나
그 다음에 나중에 건물 취득세 나중에
또 뭐 민원 처리하면서 비용이 또
발생될 수도 있거든요 그런 것까지
감안은 하셔야 된다 좀 많은 분들이
되게 궁금해서 좀 영상으로 찍고
싶었어요 전에 영상에도 보셨겠지만
강남 프로젝트 저희가 이제 두 번째
모집을 하는데
댓글이 좀 많이 달리더라구요
연락도 좀 많이 오고 아예 이렇게 좀
영상으로
담으면 좋을 것 같아서
영상을 찍게 되었습니다 그래서
여러분들 건물 매입하시는데 있어서
도움이 되셨으면 좋겠고 좀 이렇게
생각보다
신축 비용뿐만 아니라
다른 비용도 다 들어간다 대출
이자까지도 감안을 해야 된다 뭐 이런
것까지도 좀 알고 계시면 좋을 것
같습니다 정리를 해볼게요 그래서
매입하는 비용 그 다음에 취득세 그
다음에 중개수수료
법무사 비용도 들어갈 수도 있고
그리고
멸실하면서 멸실 비용
근데 여기서 해체감리까지 하면은
기간이 좀 더 늘어나고 해체 감리하는
사람 비용도 발생되고 그 다음에 건축
설계 비용
또 들어가고 그 다음에 나중에
대출이자 대출이자 어찌됐든 공사하면서
계속 돈을 내긴 하지만 근데
여러분들도 아셔야 될게이 비용이
이렇게 없어지는게 아니라 나중에
임대수익을 받으면 그게 또 이제 상계
처리가 돼요 상계 처리가 됩니다 이거
알고 계셔야 돼요 일단은 뭐이자 비용
나가는 것도 어쨌든 돈을 가지고
있어야 되고 그 마지막으로 건물
취득세 고려를 하셔야 됩니다 저도
실제로 건물을
지어봤고 그리고 저도 지금 건설사랑
설계사도 저희가 같이 운영하고
있으면서 큰 비용 나가는 거 위주로
좀 정리를 했습니다 그래서 오늘 영상
여기까지 하고요 여러분들 건물
매입하시고 나중에 이제 신축할 때
비용까지 좀 선정해서 말씀드렸는데
아마 도움이 많이 되실 것 같아요
참고하셔서 좀 성공적인 빌딩 투자
하셨으면 좋겠습니다 만약에 반응이
좋으면 제가
리모델링 사례까지 저 리모델링도
했었잖아요
리모델링 관련 비용도 한번 좀 산정해
보도록 하겠습니다
오늘 영상 여기까지 하겠습니다
감사합니다
[음악]